welcome to this video against deranged
let's see arranged okay get oh yeah now
you can do that see 65 I think this is a
better setup than we should be to him
this kind of thing hmm i don't know how
does black play a five or a six oh
that's interesting way to play okay go
see 5 i'm going to close the position
let's see what he's doing now probably
night a six or something here 97 hmm
maybe I don't want to cast off at the
moment maybe I can just threaten the d6
pawn for a moment k is going to take I
ok well with my RT Bishop c2 I might
have made it a bit easier for him to
play be 50 K which he is not angling
fried all it seems night h5 and I don't
know really you go for f5 in this
position
hmm ok well f5 is not playable now and
just as I say it you will probably play
it 95 or so is some looking very very
strong against that ok let's do this ok
so i probably just you still prepare
that I don't know ok it looks like it's
the ones to play at five however I think
after f5 I can take G takes Wow
hmm okay what is the idea here Queen d2
you go what King h7 cannot believe that
f5 bishop age six maybe okay let's see
he just equals King h7 okay just in this
diagonal so that f5 is never ever
possible okay I'm just going to prevent
a 5-4 good see sometimes you can even
play Knight f5 in the right moment but
it really must be the right moment won't
won't happen so often the only question
in this position is where am I putting
my own king yeah back to g2 I don't know
they cannot really castle long here that
is some bit of a problem
Jeff I don't know what to do with my
king in this position I mean why it is
definitely in okay shape here that
that's that's clearly pretty clear but I
don't really know how to play it it's
very complicated as it is often the case
with some Kings Indian positions frankly
speaking quite often blacks position s
is just just not any good but it is
always kind of yeah difficult to play
you have a hard time sometimes to decide
what to do g4 is going nite f4 so I
don't want to do that and it's really
not easy to to decide what to do here g4
again is going nite a form not a good
idea but well I don't really see what
active plan he has maybe I just had four
and b6 them and go from them this is
protected Blackie four and so on okay
maybe he wants to go back to back to the
seven now with this with this night okay
so we should be three or not I'm not
sure about that I think I should
probably make sure that I castle at some
moment at least why should I just put
the king in the middle maybe
mm-maybe is angling for Bishop g5 just
prevent that or Bishop to d8 sometimes
okay so let's let's get this out of the
middle and double on the CFL I cannot
cannot be bad really I have a long time
quite a lot
right on g two words really sucking us
peace just prevent 94 or any movement of
that night and eat my night on g2
improved if i manage that then the
position will be very good oh I all we
looked at
okay now i would look 95 that is stupid
my position is still pretty good but of
course it wasn't the best to just give
away the exchange yeah at least I'm I'm
playing some quick moves them the deep
porn is still mighty strong
that's not easy to play for black not at
all
let's try to be a bit quick hmmm yeah
they all look good baby with the pawn
I'm not sure about this 44 D 6 Queen d5
stuff like that Knight to g5 is also
quite nice but let's start with that he
wants to play route 66 song so I thought
it wasn't really threatening time
morning that it all looks nice but how
how do I actually win here
don't have a clear idea how to win night
to see five would be good but I don't
see how to to get there it's a bit risky
but I don't want to just sit around f
four runs into this check it's pretty
awkward maybe had d7 here
and a half in no time I have no time and
he's simply check and playing some quick
stuff check oops black ok open ahead
four seconds yeah well it was that was a
kind of shaky yeah I shouldn't I
shouldn't really allow night c5 but it
was still a good position somehow yeah
it is still a very good position without
any doubt now this is the deep on and
the overall activity is excellent but I
couldn't really figure out how to win
okay Bishop t6 would have won the
exchange back okay I thought just don't
go into this and see from here but maybe
I don't really maybe I don't have a win
there especially with a little time it's
this is kind of tricky yeah here I
couldn't find a way forward okay the
engine wants to go here Bishop a 93 95
and sees no defense against that that
looks quite logical I cannot move any of
that cannot move anything
yeah that's a win there's nothing he can
do against this yeah I I kind of
shuffled every I didn't really didn't
see a way forward again we should be
three years winning yeah I had the idea
to put the night on c5 but this is
definitely risky the seven would would
win again yeah it's try it's tricky to
analyze here we both had just just a
couple of seconds there the the opening
was kind of weird yeah here here Jim I
mean maybe he can play a five maybe he
can do that it looks it looks very very
risky in a way but maybe he can do it I
thought g4 is an idea or let's say that
was what I wanted to do yes that move
now that's very messy the computer likes
white but that's very messy never know
what's going to happen but this is this
is a strange decision if you play for
all that you should go I five I think
now with the King there you never get a
five in the our computer is fearless
wants to go g4 but I don't want to give
them any activity yeah like this is this
is happening then at the computer just
gives plus one but do you want to give
black all of a sudden this when you
don't have a good King position I don't
want in the Blitz game this is just good
for wide yeah that's just very good for
what I control the C file and black has
no clear player tho those pieces are all
bad okay well thanks for watching